beautiful shot the u.s capitol has
partially reopened this week but only
partially the complex has been largely
shuttered to tourists and school groups
since march 2020 as congressional
correspondent scott mcfarland reports
even the reopening has been bogged down
by confusion controversy and some
politics
wave everybody wave
11 hours on the bus to make it to
washington the students from central
middle school in port huron michigan
eventually arrived at the capitol it's
something something really big for them
and like something really big for me too
because like here like here like i'm
sick
but they noticed something was missing
from the people's house
many of the people what are you like
inside from past years you can't show
this year so the two things i would say
the most statuary hall
and then the rotunda some tour groups
returned to the u.s capitol this week
but many restrictions remain from a
shutdown of the campus that began at the
outset of the pandemic in march 2020.
staff are permitted to lead tours but
only six hours a day and during midday
hours only with groups no larger than
50. central middle schools group was too
large in a report to the senate earlier
this spring the senate sergeant-at-arms
revealed a full reopening of the capitol
complex including the capitol visitors
center won't be complete until 2023 and
like so much in washington even the
campus restrictions are a wedge issue
with republicans criticizing democratic
leaders it's sad
and there's no reason for it there's no
reason for it
when cbs news pressed top congressional
officials for answers we heard different
answers about the reopening i got
members of both parties saying they'd
like it to happen wider and faster
because they're saying no to school
groups yeah no it's not can you use your
office to make it happen faster
well since i'm not the
house capital physician no i can't if i
ruled the world that we wouldn't have
coveted but it is we all
want our kids people to come this is the
people's house but the senate
sergeant-alarms told senators the
closures are not about health the
limiting factor right now is not covid
related but an insufficient number of
uniformed police officers to man the
many positions associated with the
capital visitors center
including she said due to the impact of
the january 6 attack capitol police tell
cbs news they're trying to tackle those
shortages aiming to hire and deploy 280
more officers by september but in the
meantime the restrictions on tour groups
remain in place here at the capitol
which means during this peak of
sightseeing season there are fewer sites
to see at the center of american
democracy until at least
next summer
for cbs saturday morning i'm scott
mcfarland at the capitol
that's a a major trip for a lot of kids
in middle school is that trip to dc and
really sad if you're going to miss out i
mean there's a couple things i think
everybody can agree on and that is
people should be able to visit yeah the
people's house one and two it should be
safe and secure right i don't understand
why the issue of covid
my natural reaction was oh it's a safety
issue it's a staffing issue well that's
what the sergeant of arms says yeah but
but the the health issue um i don't
understand that that reasoning
i think they're figuring it out okay how
about shocking politics